[Music]
this is not just her everybody's
disappeared you know the rules hotness
you know keep off these bars blah blah
all of that [ __ ] cats gonna get the
chair I can't wait to show you munch
toys
we psychotic anti-social free flyer
careful
[Music]
the youtubers is Charlie so they confirm
Margot Robbie is getting a spinoff
Harley Quinn movie so let's break it
down a couple pretty solid ideas about
what they're gonna do with it you all
probably heard that they confirm Margot
Robbie is going to produce as well as
develop the next Harley Quinn movie or
the first Harley Quinn movie technically
Suicide Squad was her first movie but
she's getting her own solo movie there
are a couple pretty solid bets about
what that movie is going to be one I
think it's going to be Gotham City siren
style as in there will be other female
characters may be the official Gotham
City sirens like Catwoman and poison ivy
with Harley Quinn but whatever the a
story is going to be the B story is
definitely going to be Joker centric
because they were two of the most
popular things to come out of Suicide
Squad and now I think one of the
problems was is that they tried to
change the type of movie it was with the
editing like originally they were gonna
do something that was a little more true
to the comics in the Joker and Harley
Quinn very much together but you get the
sense that he's very abusive of her but
I think the version of the movie that
ended up on screen tried to edit some of
that stuff out that made him seem really
terrible so that their relationship
seemed more loving even though that's
not the way I read it coming out of the
movie theater but maybe they should
because I've read the comics and I'm
trying to read between the lines but if
you haven't read the comics and you saw
the movie maybe you had a different
reading of their relationship but based
on what David Ayer has said in all the
Joker stuff that they took out of the
movie like they took a ton of Joker
material out of the movie a lot of that
stuff that was taken out made him seem
like a way bigger dirtbag and of course
I'm expecting to see Batman in there
somewhere maybe not a huge part of the
film but unless they travel somewhere
else for the movie it's going to be a
Gotham centric movie so of course you're
going to run into Batman but here's
where we get into rumor mill territory
because there's been talk about the way
they're reorganizing the DC movie
schedule a little bit because originally
they didn't have a Man of Steel to on
the schedule so it sounds like they're
reorganizing some of the movies that are
a little further off so the rumor is
right now is that the official Suicide
Squad sequel Suicide Squad 2 won't
happen for many years in favor of
pushing up
more solo films like Harley Quinn in the
Joker
so we'll see more of the good stuff from
Suicide Squad and it'll be a little bit
easier for them to sidestep some of the
story issues give them time to write a
really good Suicide Squad story because
one of the biggest problems with Suicide
Squad is that David Ayer only had about
six weeks to write his scripts usually
most really good big movies like this
took at least a year to write if not
more than that so you've all heard about
Geoff Johns DC course Corrections one of
the other things I think they're trying
to do just as a general rule of thumb
now is not rush films that aren't ready
yet so like not announcing movie release
dates before they have a really good
script in their hands so yes there's
gonna be a Suicide Squad sequel with you
know probably some roster changes but
the Harley Quinn movie will drop way
before that and that will enable them to
follow up on some of the really big
Batman stuff - like The Associated
Batman backstory so like when we saw
Harley Quinn's info card it said she was
involved in the death of Robin they will
be able to follow up on that before the
next Suicide Squad film so in addition
to having some more fun with a really
cool character in a really good
performance Margot Robbie's performance
was one of the best ones in the film she
was one of the best things about that
you can also do more world building in
the DC movie universe because everything
is connected but since we've only had
our first couple films they're still
building connections between all these
characters like Superman really hasn't
interacted with any of these Batman
characters yet the other Justice League
members probably don't care about what's
going on in Gotham or Metropolis so once
we get the Justice League next year
you'll see that spin out we'll probably
see Harley Quinn and Joker somewhere in
there released Easter eggs for where
they're at as of the end of Suicide
Squad
because Joker broke in and busted her
out meaning they're back on Batman's
radar officially but his first task is
assembling the Justice League so I have
a feeling you know like if you've ever
watched any version of Batman The Back
computer has files in tracks almost
everybody that's a person of interest to
Batman
both villain and hero which is why a lot
of people thought I was weird and that
post-credit scene for Suicide Squad that
he had to get that information from
Amanda Waller everyone's like wooden mat
man have already gotten that information
through his own means really you can
chalk that
to them wanting to throw forward to
Justice League for people that don't
necessarily look that deep into the
story but like if you've read comics
you're like hey wait a minute
Batman's the world's greatest detective
he hasn't done a lot of detective work
in this movie so far but now I think the
Geoff Johns is on board kind of helping
oversee all this stuff and all these
characters I think that little details
like that won't slip through the cracks
anymore and then he kind of do a version
of that where Amanda Waller references
Batman's nighttime activities he talks
about the stuff that they were doing
with Suicide Squad so he knows about all
that shady stuff she's been doing she
being Amanda Waller of course knows that
he is Batman so there is a level of
awareness between these characters it's
just that sometimes the moments that
they film that let you know that end up
getting cut out of the final film but
thankfully they had stuff like this I
think my favorite part of that
post-credit scene wasn't the Justice
League part where he's like me and my
friends will do it it was the part where
she let him know that she knows he's
Batman that was so much fun but let me
know in the comments what do you want to
see them do in the Harley Quinn movie do
you want to see Gotham City sirens I
know we all want to see Catwoman come
back to this universe they even if they
wanted to do Gotham City sirens I feel
like they could do it with just the two
of them with Catwoman Harley Quinn let
me know Catwoman
poison ivy do you want to see them in
the Harley Quinn movie or do you just
want to see a Harley Quinn Joker movie
in none of those other characters I feel
like they're not going to waste the
opportunity to introduce a couple more
cool Batman universe characters though
but congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Chad Benjamin you win a
gift certificate for the flash season 2
blu-ray just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there is a
new round that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so we're still a couple weeks away
from all the DC shows coming back but
Gotham all technically Gotham is coming
back tomorrow
it's a DC show but it's not really
connected to the other DC shows so I
will be doing a Gotham episode 1 video
agents of shield premieres on Tuesday so
we got that coming back Luke Cage is the
week after that then the week after that
like in two weeks from now that's when
we get all the other DC shows so get
hype it's going to be really awesome
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about
Batman's new costume in Justice League
and you can
here for the first couple of minutes
from agents of shield that's dropping on
Tuesday thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight